some of you are so talented and the
right person fell in love subjectively
on your art gave you love and you
exploded but for the 99.9 percent of you
you need to spend the next nine years
building community building narrative of
who you are as an artist and build up
the fact that you even can
is something you should be grateful for
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
why have you doped so deep into nfts
i think the biggest reason i've gone so
hard into nfts is
for me subjectively and intuitively i
believe that it is
the biggest consumer shift since
social media and web 2.0 that that it is
very clear to me
based on my instincts and my history in
business and kind of being a
behavioralist now i'm realizing watching
what people do
that this will happen this has happened
and i just don't see a world where
nfts are not an infrastructure in our
society right now it's very obvious that
it's collectibles and art
but these are smart contract
visualization right so this is
homes and leases and
i i can't imagine not every ticket being
an nft in a decade so once i realized it
was this big big i only know one move
all in
what was that realization for you
you know it's funny i was just talking
to somebody what was my realization i i
can't actually
recall the singular piece of content
that was the eureka moment but it was
december 30th through
mid-january this two three week special
period of time where between six seven
nine hours a day
you know if i was really busy at work
7 p.m to midnight if i was a little less
you know i was hacking at it cutting a
45-minute meeting to 15 so i could get
30 to get 30 minutes more of what is an
nft or
a counterpoint to something that i was
feeling i think i wanted a well-rounded
point of view but
i remember the it was
very it was i might have been the day
before valentine's day i'm remembering
it's mid-february
where i truly had the
true eureka moment where i stood up
from my laptop at my kitchen table stood
up and said thank you god because i
realized that not only did i recognize
there was this new big shift like i saw
in
dot com and like i saw on social
but i was a unique position of my career
where i had
leverage financially for the first time
in the three times uh reputation
community but most of all
it was also about in its first phase
collecting flipping
knowing
like that's what i'm good at i've been
training for 40 years in sports cards
in comic books in toys in garage sales
in premium wine
i've been training for this moment my
whole life so
um the eureka moment happened in in it
was happening from december to mid
february
and there's really no turning back now
so like one thing your master has brand
building so when looking at brands
specifically big brands like what's the
biggest potential for them in the nft
space and like what does a successful
foray look like for a big brand moving
into nfts you know if you're a big brand
a fortune 500 a fortune 5000
the biggest opportunity
is that you you you've learned from
social media
right
social media was a place where brands
were too slow
and two brands
meaning
they weren't authentic enough they
weren't transparent enough they weren't
clever enough they weren't cool enough
they weren't relevant enough
and that just happened that was
2005-6789
my hope and we'll see because big
companies love to do things wrong
my hope is that the executives are still
there they remember the feelings of how
wrong they were about facebook and
twitter and instagram and youtube
and they say
maybe we need to do this differently a
i'm already feeling that
b
here's the big one brands
unlike everything you do in marketing
where you can hide behind a headline
or a fake report
when you launch an nft project
the entire world has access
to the fact of it being successful or
not
think about that so number one goal and
and you know i started a company called
vayner nft to work with brands is i'm
trying to slow down brands don't do an
nft project to get a headline and be
like oh we're clever
you need to do an nft project that's
actually successful
and uh
my real hope is that people realize that
you're now on the record and you're
selling something this isn't a marketing
campaign
it can be a marketing campaign but you
still have results and so i'm really
excited about it so uh to flip that a
little bit for smaller for artists who
are just coming into nfps from smaller
entrepreneurs what's what's one tip or a
few tips you give them uh within in
terms of getting started in nfps
you know the biggest thing i think about
when i think about small artists or
entrepreneurs is a
kiss the ground right now you are so
fortunate to be in a moment like this
this is special this is a gold rush
you know most of us actually let me
phrase all of us were not alive when
everybody in new york or st louis were
like hey if you go to california you
gotta pick and shovel you could get gold
like we didn't this is that big of a
deal now if you're a historian of the
gold rush yes there were many people and
still families to this day that trade on
uncle tom's great move to going to
california back then but there was a lot
of people that lost money
a lot of people that got sick a lot of
people that got depressed so my number
one
by far
point of view is be grateful and patient
be grateful that you're at a moment
that's this big you are a person that
was going to be a
graphic designer at a company and now
you're famous in making millions that's
wild
but be patient just like influencer
marketing for every charlie demilio and
logan paul there's a lot of people in
the middle and the long tail that are
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
doing something they love and that's
even more exciting in my mind
so you don't need to be a millionaire
like ferocious and ex-copy and and
people
if you're watching right now
wouldn't you love to just make art
full-time and have a roof over your head
and that's amazing that you can do that
now because it wasn't easy to make 50
000 in sales and art just two years ago
and now it's obtainable number two don't
be audacious
the number one thing i'm seeing now is
artists getting mad they're not
successful matt
the entitlement is extraordinary
just because you're making art doesn't
mean people should spend money on it
people like gary you're well of course
yours is doing well you had a big
community i'm like i earned my community
i worked for the last 15 years i spent
all of 2007 to 2011
15 hours a day answering people on
twitter i did that
just because you haven't yet
that's okay because you can start right
now being active on discord and twitter
and clubhouse and come to art basel and
network
but it's gonna take you time it's going
to take you time
some of you are so talented and the
right person fell in love subjectively
on your art gave you love and you
exploded but for the 99.9 of you you
need to spend the next nine years
building community building narrative of
who you are as an artist and build up
the fact that you even can
is something you should be grateful for
and to kind of wrap up this part of it
with coinbase nft coming you know we
have tens of millions of users what what
do you see happening when potentially 70
million plus people get on board for the
nfc economy let there be no confusion
and not because i'm sitting here with
you all because i'm always on the record
there is no bigger thing brewing
right now in the space than the
potential of what this coinbase thing
may be
if this hits and you get that much of an
influx of first-time users because a
platform that people used on the
financial side have a very easy way to
get into nft because they're playing
within the ecosystem that they're
accustomed to
i mean i'm holding my breath out of
excitement
by the way because i like to shoot it
straight it may not be a windfall maybe
a lot of those people but
even a million
new people is staggering to this space
because we're still in the hundreds of
thousands
and so
i'm antsy in the best way meaning i just
can't wait for you all to get it done
because i just want to see what's going
to happen those first 30 days i'm
excited for the artists i'm excited for
the projects
you know i am macro concerned in general
that everyone's too focused on the money
and and if you think about a lot more
people coming in prices will go up and
people might even get more about the
money and money matters that's how you
pay for food you can't tough to trade
art right now for a bacon cheeseburger
but
i i do think that people have to be
thoughtful about their behavior um but
to answer your question directly
the moment is extraordinary and it is
one of the big moments of 2022 because
if it hits
it takes the space to a completely
different level
thank you
so let's switch gears a little bit uh do
the behind the wallet thing do you have
like your nft collection accessible on
your phone
where's my phone the gallery i know you
have your gallery link let me know if
they just like kind of scroll down what
we've been doing people is we're getting
some shots of them scrolling through
their nfts and just like just asking a
couple questions about their collection
why they bought and stuff
so let us know when you got that pulled
out
the problem is
my visual might be a little challenging
and i think we need to be thoughtful
i'll tell you why
so many people spam dropped me
see anything that happened do you have
like a
liked or a favorites gallery i don't but
i can give you like one awesome i got an
idea i got an idea can you help this
now
you guys i assume have no problem if
it's open c or you do
no okay um
i think the main important thing is like
to get the story behind
like why you're gravitating to this
project like 100 what's what's your vibe
on it and like
totally um maybe even some questions
like if you had one f and of t to hold
on for
ever what would it be type of game so i
can i can absolutely scroll here and
give you i got a great way to start
um i'm just gonna riff play with me here
for a sec
you know when i go through my collection
uh
you know women and weapons world of
women plasma bears
um creature world me bits
uh brain vomit as i keep scrolling and
you know deadheads
um swamp verse these are all things on
chain monkeys
mfr's punk comics curio cards crypto
punks
ford ape um cool cats
they all have stories to me right
strawberry.wftwtf
avastar's the icon you know as i keep
going through these
they've all have meaning to me long neck
ladies right i remember when i bought
them why i bought them um
what was on my mind what was i thinking
about what got me excited that day
lamelo balls collectible is that right
like early in sports people of somebody
i believed in
i was very scared to buy nba top shop
because i thought most would go down not
because i think nba topshop's amazing i
just know how collectible cards work
99 go to garbage because they don't
become lebron right so buying lamellae
because i thought lamella was going to
be a beast right um
you know mumbot you know her work uh
monkey bet dao i remember thinking oh a
casino on the chain with art um you know
candy digital which i'm on the board of
sports cards similar to nba um you know
just it's fun to like scroll through
here and think about alpha betty doodles
right kind of kids book first time i saw
uh wanted to do something around autism
like i felt compelled to you know pick
those up um koala intelligence agency it
was a hot one that popped i'm like could
this be the next board ape and i spent a
ton of money on the number one rarity
one the project is still doing nicely
but it didn't become that and boy did i
lose a lot of money on that and that's
like fun for me i'm like that's a i knew
i was taking a high risk high reward bet
on that um
cool cats events airdrop tokens from
owning it that's fun to see in my wallet
choose one community yeah yeah which one
would you like what's your favorite one
that you're a part of
one community that i'm most
um
thrilled to be a part of probably
some sort of tie between creature world
i would say the following because it's
just the truth that i'm not trying to be
politically correct
world of women creature world
brain vomit
women and weapons
all kind of sit
in a very
curio cards a little bit but i'm a
little less active those four
kind of really sit in the same place to
me they represent
four projects
that have real artists
they represent four projects that have
real artists
that have real community
that
feel to me that the majority of the
makeup is not
day trading flipping life which i don't
think is bad i just think it's bad when
people like i'm here for the community
but what they're really saying is i just
want my bag to go
those four stand out as like okay
there's a high enough and they got
plenty of flippers in those four
communities but there's enough people in
those communities
there's enough people in those
communities that
i think
really care of like i want to own this
art for 17 years
it makes me want to go in there and
and i like going in there when i see the
floor dropping
because as the elder statesman i like
going in there and being like patience
right and everyone gets excited because
kind of like
everyone's too stock broker right now
when things are going down their their
vibes down
and i like going into those communities
reminding everybody but you're here for
the art
so who cares if it's a dollar or if it's
four million dollars if you're holding
it you're good
right and so those four stand out as
communities i enjoy being a part of last
question
if you had to choose one nfc to pass on
to your kids that they would never be
able to sell what would it be
if i had to pick
this is the difference between me and
drock's ghetto style where we just film
regardless of the [ __ ] background
noise
and us respecting other really amazing
creatives that we know prefer to not
have that [ __ ] in the background i
[ __ ] think it's great that [ __ ] fires
me up but i also sleep with a sound
machine at max noise
so chaos keeps me comfortable i think
that'll make sense to all of you um
what's that you're ready for bed yeah no
[ __ ] trains to this day drock trains
like weirdly get me tired because i grew
up by a train track in edison and when
the train would go out lights out that's
how i got into time i think to sound
machines i think the reason i like sound
machine so much is
the thing that consistently put me
directly to sleep was when i would hear
the train from afar coming out and when
it passed that's when i would sleep
which is why i live in new york city
easily and all that other [ __ ] that's
why i'm an entrepreneur i prefer the
chaos
if i had to give one nft to my kids that
wasn't a v friend
i would probably give them
it's a really tough question i would
probably give them my x copy plasma bear
there's a project from 2018
there's a pro
we also gotta go and find it we'll get
it we'll get it we'll get it
no you're the best thank you
there's there's a project from 2018
called plasma bears that really matters
to me one
world of women
women and weapons mumbot
you know my mother is my hero
my business hero even though she never
spent the day in a business
we're going to keep that in the
background this time because it is from
my heart
so
i've been very thoughtful and
and
focused on
trying to seek out female artists that i
enjoy
plasma bears done by a female
project in 2018. angelique is no g
had five or six or ten different artists
make the bears one of those artists was
x-copy
x copy in the last three four years has
gone on to become easily one of the most
collectible and most expensive and most
sought after artists in the world
gary me
as a collector loves providence and
origin it's why i like nft
the fact that somebody
did a little project for probably a
couple of bucks i don't know the details
but went on to become the x copy
there's something just everything for me
about it it's actually happening right
now there's a bunch of kids right now
doing stuff that in seven years are
gonna be the ones and the stuff they're
making right now is grossly underpriced
from a collectible historical value
female lead project in 2018
x copy made three bears
and here's the best part they did it on
a side chain
that side chain failed
layer two
it
crashed disappeared
the bears were on there they gave the
community this chain
very little time to know that you could
get your bears over so many of the bears
burn
in the ether
gone
like in essence my favorite stories
burned in a fire right like
why mickey mantle's rookie cards are so
valuable tops threw them in the water
so like everything that my collector and
origin and providence is happened in
this project
female base project early by the way
burnt lost bears so there's less than
there should be
and
one of the five most important artists
made it i figured that out found three x
copy full bears because it was like
build-a-bear you had to buy the pieces
to make the bear i found three clean x
copies every arm everybody every heart
every head
was from x copy i have three clean bears
right now they are my prized possession
nft youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee first of all thank you so much i
hope you're doing super well during
these times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight this is the time to
subscribe i hope you consider it and i
hope i see you soon